quand on arrive dans les locaux de sa
société où se mêlent plantes vertes
bougies et statuettes
on est loin d'imaginer le métier de
corinne cette femme hyperactive est à la
tête d'une société de déménagement un
milieu a priori très masculin mais pour
elle son statut de femme est plutôt un
atout
au départ c'est vrai que ce n'était pas
forcément bien ressenti mais aujourd'hui
le déménagement se féminise à son grand
avantage
il faut pas oublier que quand vous
déménagez cantat couple déménage une
famille c'est bien souvent madame qui
gère le déménagement la proche d'une
femme sur une opération de déménagement
répond certainement aux besoins et non
exprimées parfois des clients et ça
amène effectivement une touche plus
personnelle
en plus de cette activité corps il
continue son premier métier hôtesse de
l'air un emploi du temps bien fourni qui
l'a pas empêché de prendre au fil des
années de plus en plus de
responsabilités
elle est notamment vice présidente de la
chambre syndicale du déménagement
d'ile-de-france et au début elle a dû se
battre pour s'y imposer
alors départ j'ai été perçu comme
l'hôtesse de l'air qui se mêlent de quoi
de caisse
donc c'est vrai que il a certainement
fallu que je leur prouve quelque chose
même si personnellement j'en ressentais
pas le besoin
mais en étant naturelle et en défendant
mes idées je pense que
ils m'ont acceptée la preuve en est lui
à ce poste à corinne ne s'arrête jamais
avec son associé et marie elle gère une
vingtaine de salariés réalisent mille
chantiers par an et se déplacent partout
dans le monde en tant que navigatrice un
mode de vie difficiles à conjuguer avec
vie familiale aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus facile puisque mes filles en 25 et
28 ans dans quel sens tu nommes elles
volent de leurs propres ailes
c'était plus compliqué quand il était
petit
notamment à cause de mon métier de
navigante c'est vrai que je les ai pas
beaucoup vu grandir ça a été un peu le
drame le manque de ma vie certes